all right so I've got this term
metaphysics up there and you read
something that visits the selections but
I gave you four today which are just a
few parts and that you've heard this
trick metaphysics before right
I'm guessing what are you associated
with gentlemen we talked about this
earlier in the semester chakras and
crystals and things that massage there
and this kind of like to talk about
people up to the Omega Institute down
the road from here yeah that is
metaphysics in a way but that's not the
sort of about physics that were talking
about here that's not the original
meaning of metaphysics Arizona's the guy
who actually points the phrase and he
didn't do it by you know by compass it's
sort of an accident of history he wrote
a lot of books and you know back to any
of these books and they were in the
scrolls that's why it sounds like the
book Monti book to book three and the
reading selection each book was a scroll
you could only fit so much on a scroll
we call these chapters now and he wrote
all these these texts and then they were
placed in a kind of order and physics is
about what you study physics it's about
chaos bacteria that's biology right
what's physics about didn't even take
physics in high school what do you
remember messing around with yeah yeah
measure like how fast things fall all
those equations for that you didn't mix
chemicals together if that was chemistry
you know we have a Bunsen burners you
know start things on fire mess around
and we'll have physics is a little bit
less interesting at least from the lab
perspective because most environments I
guess you know if you get to shoot
things at things that's that's probably
fun but everything else is like let's
see how much the spring will expand and
contract it's about the physical world
it's about the the elements that make
things up you know how they work
together well Aristotle he had a
conception of physics nobody really pays
that much attention to things work and
it's you know horribly uploaded but
metaphysics is is something that is
about not just the physical world but
being as such so Aristotle had these
treatises where he's talking about not
just this kind of being you know let's
pretend this is you know physics it's
not just this it's everything else that
physics fits into so what do say physics
and mathematics and chemistry and
psychology and economics and political
science all these things have income
they're all about things that are that
exist that being that's a hard thing to
wrap your your head around he didn't
call this being ology he didn't really
call it much of anything but because the
books in which he wrote about this came
after the physics they called it meta
whose eqing after the physics in Greek
so it became metaphysics that's where we
got this word from and then people just
started using
after after that so metaphysics is
really about the nature of things and
from Aristotle this is going to be tied
in with this conception causes we're
going to talk a lot about causes in this
class section and let's just think a
little bit about that causes in general
so I'm gonna drop this what just
happened
what's that gravity happened yeah that's
a good way to put it
gravity acted as a cause to make some
events the keys falling
banging they're not broken which is good
felling I dropped a delicate mace
gravity would be responsible for that as
well all right but also is that all
that's going on you know what stopped us
at the table right gravity did one thing
the table did another thing and we have
an event this house is at the whole
picture gravity acting well who put the
keys bless you who put the keys there in
the first place I did right why did the
keys actually fall instead of just you
know sort of flitting down like a
feather
exactly yeah they're made of heavy stuff
if we made the keys out of my small so
would it wouldn't be very good cheese
very conveniently but you could imagine
that they probably would have you know
kind of walked down like a feather would
there's all sorts of reasons why things
turned out the way they did we can ask
us about other things like why are you
wearing that sweatshirt today you just
put it on but you couldn't just like
walk around with nothing all right so
there's a cause why is it a mere
sweatshirt pretty simple barest right
usually there's at least I mean look
around right now there's four people in
MERIS spirit your make sense you're at
Marist College that's a explanation
that's a cause for something and you're
probably not that used to thinking about
this in very abstract generic terms when
do we ask for a cause usually in human
affairs when we want to figure out who's
to blame right that's that's usually
where we we start somebody did something
somebody must be to blame who is the
cause of this action here what else
would you do start thinking about causes
okay yeah here's somebody does something
incomprehensibly what what is that guy
do it and somebody says by these
juggling eggs down the middle of the
interstate haven't you said yeah I know
what he's doing
why is he doing that what's the what's
the reason innovation you're asking for
something beyond just the phenomenon
itself you know what's happening you
want to know why it's happening causes
our answers to the question why and I
don't want to dwell on this too much
because I do want to get into the text
but think about how many of you have
babysat little brothers or sisters or
nieces or nephews or cousins or the kids
down the street who are from say about
three years old too you know six or
seven anything what's the one thing that
they drive me nuts with that's being
loud once I get sugared up asking you
why write those wise can go on forever
it seems like
you're trying to do your homework what
are you doing my homework why because I
have to get ready for class why'd you
have to do that well because I want to
do well in the class why do you want to
do well in the class because I want to
graduate mister getting more because
they they of course you know all this
why do you want to graduate well so I
can go to college why do you want to go
to college to get a good job you know by
the time you're done so I can have you
know be a success in life and you know
have everything squared away now leave
me alone all we've been doing is asking
you the same question over and over
again why asking for clauses and the
fact that you could actually like trace
that out that means that there wasn't
order to the logical order if I were to
ask any of you why are you here at
Marist you could give me some sort of
the answer and then you can give me
another answer in another answer and it
would eventually encompass your entire
life and what you want your life to look
like wouldn't it or anybody just you're
embarrassed when you happen to walk you
know on campus and there was a dorm room
available so you said I'll help I'll
just do this no let me kind of weird
maybe there's some schools where people
do that Marist is not one of them
because America lost a lot of money so I
think all of you are here because you
have something definite in mind for
yourself down the road and that's a
whole chain of pauses well do what
Aristotle is actually going to call the
final causes which is what we're going
to talk about more in the second part of
the class what we're going to talk about
here is desire desire for knowledge
and then we're going to talk about the
four causes how they work and then we're
going to look at Aristotle's criticisms
of this guy in pet achlys and why in
pedigrees because I'm technically said
that love or friendship is a
metaphysical principle of answer to the
question why why things are the way they
are the entire universe is pervaded by
my love or friendship and also by its
opposite
that's a metaphysical point of view and
Aristotle is going to be criticizing
that so we're going to look at that and
then if we have time we'll look at this
notion of final cause here why so if we
start out give us this this sentence has
become very famous
we never go in like websites where
there's quotations by certain people you
need a quotation on from Plato this is
one of the quotations you'll find from
Aristotle all men bited by nature
desires to them now does he mean does he
mean that the actual gender sense all
men desire to know when it really
couldn't be bothered with that sort of
thing what do you think no it's it's a
translation of the term ontour false
which means human being all human beings
by nature desired to know and he says
you know how do we know this well here's
one indication the delight we take in
our senses even a person their
usefulness it's good to be able to see
things right or hear things helps you
get around you don't follow to open you
know manholes or or down the ditch or
bang yourself on the wall what do you
want to eat something it's nice to be
able to open the fridge and look inside
and see what's there
you we also take delight just in using
our senses what do you actually get out
of looking at pink so I'm gonna feed you
so I'm going to tell you how to close
yourself or house yourself we're too
good job a matter of fact if you spend
all day looking at paintings you
probably won't have a job but we enjoy
it or thinking about music may be
blessing what do we actually get out of
listening to the music that is almost
ubiquitous in our lives and join them
right you may not think about this in
terms of knowing but when you buy that
new album by the band that you like you
want to know what's on there you want to
experience it don't you
or would you just be happy with reading
some critics review of them track one is
a beautiful little area about blah blah
blah blah blah track tuning so I've got
that I don't need to actually listen to
it today if you do them or in iTunes
right iTunes you can have this you can
click and the drop down review will come
in about that band and that currently
album there's sophomore effort at blah
blah blah blah blah didn't you say oh I
read that I don't need to listen to this
stuff what are you doing step yeah
or before you do that if you want to be
a really savvy buyer what does iTunes
let you do baby if you listen to the
samples why do you listen of the samples
because you want to know right is this
as good as their last album or is this
gonna be a waste of my money you want to
know something all of you want to know
things all of the time you don't really
think about it that way but that's a
basic human desire and you think about
what separates us humans from the other
animals Aristotle defines human and many
other philosophers do isn't rational
what does that rational part me
what does it mean to you I say be
rational
stop being irrational what are what am I
telling you to do yeah fair fairness is
part of it dogs don't worry about
fairness you know if you we have two
dogs at home and we'll get these rawhide
chunks and if the one dog could get both
rawhide chunks it would said great for
me screw the other dog and the other dog
feels the same way they don't like you
know it wouldn't it wouldn't be like the
dog would take the two rawhide chunks
and then think think about it say here
you go I'm sorry we do that don't we
that's a lot of them we should have but
we were concerned with fairness the
answer concern the fairness maybe maybe
you know some of our finer animals may
need dolphins in some way or chimpanzees
are concerned with that what else yeah
conscience a sense of right and wrong
yeah so rather than just fairness that's
part of being rational it's not just
reducible to pain and pleasure or being
sad about things yeah making decisions
for ourselves about how we want to be
yeah when we control ourselves we're
we're saying to herself I should not
follow this desire that I get the
animals animals can be conditioned to
disregard their desires for a while we
can actually like step back and take
positions on our own desserts and say
you know this desire
I can't indulge it right now and it's
really not as valuable as this desire
because this desires for something
better what else
you know rationality needs be able to
think things through as well being able
to that's stepping back and reflecting
and there's a lot of other things too we
you know animals communicate with each
other we speak with each other we use
terms that animal languages whatever
they happen to be don't have in them
like right and wrong or prudent an
increment rational and irrational so
that sets things up quite differently
for us we have not only the same sort of
desires and then the animals do you know
animals have a whole bundle of desires
that we have in common how many of you
ate breakfast breaking away buddy happy
now so those of you who didn't eat
breakfast are you hungry would you like
to eat your desire to eat right do you
want to eat just anything like I might
have some stale crackers anybody want
some stale crackers for breakfast or you
said now I can I can wait I can pass
would you like some stale crackers now
viewer god you'd be like sounds great
I'll have that you know we are desires
are a little bit more sophisticated a
little bit more complex than theirs our
designers can become habitual in ways
that the animal ones you know to a
certain extent they can but most put the
most part there they're rather crude and
some of those desires have to do with
others of our designers have to do with
or there are certain distinctive things
that we we take pleasure in doing and
eventually what's particularly uniquely
given beings is this sort of stuff all
feeds back into every level doesn't use
its word it's a good one to pick up
culture what is culture
I don't even remember this one like
anthropology doing doing or making I
know you have an anthropology class or
remember this from social studies
history what is culture to mean like
being game a fine like you know knowing
which fork you use when you sit down
there's like eight Forks and all those
knives in front of you and which which
why did drink with which dish is a part
of it right that's more what we call
etiquette that sweatshirt it's an
expression of culture isn't it
broadly speaking you're not gonna wear
it to like you know though the art
gallery or something because I think of
a culture that way this is what I'm
wearing right now this time this is part
of you know late modern culture it's
sort of like a sign of certain kinds of
activity right ranging from engaging in
business to teaching to leisure and
activities of a certain sort now how do
you know all that stuff how could this
be familiar to you
reborn with that knowledge
babies get out of the womb you might
need to start working on time time it's
gonna be a valuable skill for me my job
is that I'm going for whatever 18 years
old how do you know where have you
figured how have you figured most things
out did you like totally make it up as
we went along
yeah okay hands down now that when we
say tradition that's what tradition
actually means passing down drives its
you cast down from who passed up by okay
yeah that for some things it is your
family like think of a particular style
of dressing perhaps
your parents tell you this is how you
should look if I use some stuff that way
turns out you get somewhere else you're
like yeah I don't have to dress that way
we got all these other people are
dressed but you know you thought that
was oh yeah and you didn't come up with
that on your own somebody else gave that
to you somebody else originated those
ideas that's part of what culture offers
us unlike other animals we don't have to
reinvent the world every generation
that's what makes us unique in part it's
not just the capacity to think it's the
fact that some other people before us
have thought and we can go to the
library and find out what they thought
and apply that to our own lives right
think about what we're doing here in
this class this text that we're reading
is over 2,000 years old and originally
was written in Greek without punctuation
by the way
then somebody punctuated it and then
they lost most of the copies of it and
then they found some copies again
luckily some some Arabs have kept them
and those got translated from arabic
into latin then they you know check the
Greek translations after a while but
Aristotle was back in the West and here
we go today and that was you know almost
a thousand years ago that they actually
started bringing Aristotle back just to
give you sort of an idea the vastness of
this rational beings are able to provide
to each other over time what it is that
they'd actually wanted to know about and
learn what it was that they wants to
know what it was that they wanted to do
or make and they pass it down and that's
when we get what we call
this is like aristotle uses you know
this term a piston a this is which we
can also translate as knowledge or
science he also uses the word techne you
guys are all familiar with that right
because technology comes from it
technique means art or craft so
Aristotle would call some of the things
that you guys are gonna be studying
techniques and others a piston a you
know for instance anybody here plenty of
going into fashion that would be a
technique it's a skilled craft it has
its own sort of internal goods rules
that you have to learn you're gonna work
a lot I was just talking about this
before class I really respect fashion
makers because they always have to work
my time it's not the lab what do you
guys call the pleasure you do all the
cutting and sewing workshop that awful
and it's deserving of that term because
you are coming to know things through
doing and making and now what is anybody
you're planning on going into the
Natural Sciences chemistry biology
that's a that's a science and a piston a
that says anybody doing political
science that's an epistemological it
works but we have these disciplines and
you guys experienced this and I did too
we experience the world in which these
already exist and the Aristotle does too
Aristotle is is writing after a lot of
different disciplines have been
developed and he's interested in how did
we actually come to do these what did we
start thinking about very primitive
human beings do they start with
inquiring about the nature of the entire
universe when everything is made of they
usually get that through myth don't they
you know somebody cut open the belly of
this and then you know they pulled this
out that became the dry land these tears
are the rain and you know they come up
with mythological explanations one of
the sort of things that people are
interested in from the very start
technology-wise disciplines
let's say I put you guys all on a desert
island I've been deserted island with
plenty of trees and animals and maybe
even something mineral resources and
stuff like that what would you need to
figure out right away yeah yeah well now
what would you need to do in order to
survive what are the basics so you get
it eat and drink so are any vegetarians
probably wouldn't last that long because
because you know the ancestral diet is
meat in part because meat is somewhat
more efficient if you're thrown into
those sort of situations you got to
figure out how to kill things so it's
not easy to kill the animals I mean
there are there were some like the dodo
bird that would actually just like sit
there that's why we call the Dodos
that's why they call that it went
extinct but you know ancient hunters had
to do a lot of work to get their hands
on protein so the animals aren't protein
and hides and things that can be used by
disciplines to enhance one's life so
eating them drinking you got that
covered anything else that you need
probably need to know how to make
spirits a beautiful hunt that's that's a
discipline yeah I want to make shelters
I'm gonna go camping just a few so I
can't really use that as an example you
know the first time you've set up a tent
especially if it's attempted it's a
design that you're not quite used to you
feel really stupid why because you don't
you have no idea what you're doing and
nothing seems to fit right now imagine
having to make a shelter without
anything else just we're going to go on
the woods and you're gonna make some
shelter my novels my boggle at the idea
what's your use of wits craft
you know wood is craft by itself a
discipline skill a technic
yeah oh you never have to see collage
casually just watch castaway buried
Robinson Caruso he'll give you that the
Robinson Crusoe is like a whole
instruction manual for what to do when
you get stranded after yeah now you need
some companions that that's hopefully
you'd actually have some other people
that talk about otherwise all the things
you learn are gonna die with you now we
go on from this and as society becomes
more and more complex less you we
develop higher and higher levels of
disciplines that incorporate other
disciplines and eventually we develop
leisure we develop the time to just sit
around and think about things and talk
about things the manse where things like
metaphysics happen it's one of the last
sciences or disciplines to be developed
in part because you have to have leisure
to be able to you know sit back not have
to worry about basic needs and think
about why things are the way they are
political science too by the way is this
sort of thing to be able to actually
think out how should people live
together what sort of rules make sense
you need to have some some leisure it's
not something that you can do when
you're totally [ __ ] up and stressed so
that's probably enough about about
knowledge and the desire for lets
talking about these four clauses
this is a really interesting way to
think about things that you experience
in the world if some sort of thing that
you want to to know about now what are
the sort of questions that you can ask
about that would tell you about what
kind of thing it is or why it is the way
that it is here are some pictures for
theirs
these are sort of just you know fancy
terms there's let's start that's the
formal clause and the material costs so
what is this
what is that it is material what kind of
material is it it's truck and you could
be very technical it's some sort of
calcium it's not calcium carbonate right
because that's baking soda calcium
something made from limestone I think we
use writing on the chalkboard it's white
we can we can color chalk and I'm you
can get orange purple chalk all that
sort of stuff
and that's the different kind of
material right what makes the purple
chalk purple it's not just the chalk in
it they added some purple dye you know
where'd they get the purple dye probably
not from the same places the diet your
shirt probably some other perfect okay
yeah there's knowing that this is made
out of chalk does actually everything
they need to know about this thing to
fully understand what it is why not
you're rapping inside of the cha it's
not let's talk about what's in the charm
it's not how the troubles made to just
chop okay now the how the chart was made
already we have to bring in another
clause well there are some ecology the
fishing parts the one that makes the
thing happen to be what it is so I don't
know this probably came from a truck
Factory there's probably like big molds
that they push chalk goop into and then
dry there's like a whole process that
would be the efficient cause of how it
came to be what about this form is this
truck the same thing if I I'm not gonna
be able to do this very easily but Mandy
and I crushed us into fine powder and
I'm like it'll blow it out at you you
know is it the same truck in one sense
it is because it's the same manner it's
the same material it's the same
substance and that sense but it doesn't
have the same form the same shape the
same some degree essence nothing about
your body for example your body is way
more complicated than this truck
what's your body Mina we're parts of
your body no I mean like hands and
fingers but blah blah damn you right
quite a lot of good thing yeah pretty
much right what else what else you made
of living yeah a lot of those a lot of
the waters in your blood it's also other
things like your cells organs that's
gonna say Oregon's various organs that
do different things like your liver you
know filters out poisons your appendix
is supposed to too but it doesn't work
anymore
ancestors there's four reapeating around
me as I talk dependencies still work but
I just don't like ticking time bombs
your brain does your thinking for you
your heart pumps the blood your lungs
process guarantee almost miraculous ways
when you think about all the things that
are going on what else you got a bunch
of Oregon's those are actually that's
not there
you got blood you got organs let's just
put those together now you got a human
being right now you have a mess yeah you
know like a butcher's team lost you me
yeah muscles and bones yeah if you don't
have muscles you're not going to be
moving around very much and without
imagine a person without any bonus
there's an episode of Family Guy where
like Peter I don't think you can you can
even like roll around like he does
you're forgetting one really important
thing though yeah yeah without that all
the stuff you're just like woke up now
you have all these material bits for
human being and imagine we have nerds
and all the other things as well
right do you have any given meeting
let's throw all this stuff together you
know like it in Frankenstein they get
bits and pieces from different people is
that gonna work for making a human being
why not I see you shaking your head
exactly that's when aerosol is calling
the formal cause when we're dealing with
organic substances like a human being
there's a certain order a very complex
order right yeah and if that order is
gone you don't have a human being
anymore you just got meat and blood and
bones and and a big mess yeah things can
go wrong you need an analytic human
being but this formal cause think of the
form is something that's superimposed on
the manner that gives an instruction
gives it it gives it its essence now
Aristotle's major contribution besides
between of noting on these causes was to
realize that there's also a second kind
of causality called the final clause the
efficient cause what brings the thing
into being welcome times by imposing
order structure on to some sort of
manner by changing things in this way
the final clause is some sort of good
purpose or he uses the term and what's
the chalk for why did somebody impress
this form upon the truck and make all
these little bits of it it's for writing
on chalkboard right that's the purpose
the function of the charm you could say
well I could serve all sorts of other
purposes too like I could use it too
you know I could put it my key ring so
my key ring you know doesn't jingle
quite so much that's not really what
it's for is it that's an Aries event a
feature of it or you know little kids
they think that the chalk is we're
putting up their nose
oh the doctor that put all sorts of
things in their nose in their ears you
know beings you don't wanna let have
well buttons you know let them have that
that's cuz they gonna know what things
are actually for the track is not for
doing that the truck is for writing it's
not for eating
some students there's some some
professors students don't think that
some professors think that truck is for
throwing in students that's not what the
chalk is for right you can actually if
you wanted to get a jerk professor like
that say eres la would say you're
totally mistaken about the final price
of those drivers you can ask yourself
this about other things as well what is
the what is the good what is the thing
that's desired it's not here it's not
here it has to do it finally in terms
let's use another manufacturer right
what is this what would you call this I
call it a dossier but not a lot of
people know what that means so maybe
okay
I always because I'm thanks for anything
the satchel charges satchel so I make it
blow anything up so early to Sancho now
this is made of leather and some metal
and whatever it is it like thread for
stitching I guess so we know what the
material causes we know what the formal
cause is we know who the efficient cause
is coach my wife you know talk to me to
get a coach things because they're very
durable she knows that I will break them
this is like the third one of these that
yeah
ten years go through quickly what's it
for for making me is it basically just
an accessory I am sold fashionable
walking around campus like this I'm not
really a professor unless I have my my
dossier or satchel it's how you can you
can tell who's who a campus that's crazy
of nonsense if I think that's the whole
purpose of it I am I'm sadly mistaken
about what this is about what's this for
to holde they get anything to protect
stuff that's valuable like computer
which otherwise imagine if I didn't have
this I just walked around carrying this
I would break this guaranteed moving
somewhere and forget it and that would
be good but I can you know keep books in
it and you know your role for the class
it helps keep me organized helps get my
stuff from place to place and business
cards in here well there you know pens
things that a professor needs a business
person might have other stuff in their
satchel some people like to put their
luncheon well we've talked about is the
final cause what is the purpose of this
thing is it is it for other things like
maybe I should use this as a coaster
maybe not there you go no second word
it's not designed that's not it's
perfect that's not the good that is it
is intended to to serve we can say the
same thing of all sorts of things and
when we get to organic things now it
gets a little bit more complicated let's
think about human beings so weird
napping although the blood guts muscles
and they're put together in a certain
order
what's your efficient
what made you to to be to come into
existence it was not just one efficient
cause right
I mean at least two things going on one
is called mom once called dad so other
human beings were you're efficient cause
yeah you know if you have a sort of
theological conception you might say
well God was in the process somehow or
you might say something like well how
did mom and dad actually wind up
together
chance log log here's something
interesting thing about what's your
purpose what is the point of the human
being what is it human being good for
that's not so easy to answer when we're
talking about human being in general
Regan we can talk about particular kinds
of human beings where we have roles
right what is a what does it cook assume
that's what we're talking about what
does they cook good for what is the
purpose of the country museum whether
this question to make things you like to
eat what makes a cook how do people
become clothes
they're just they walk in your family's
restaurant experience can someone just
walk in off the street we hand them an
apron the spatulas they go to it yeah
you won't have a very good cook they
need training right that's an efficient
cause you gotta see how all this this
works the the food that the cook makes
was the cook they are the efficient
cause in that case and they are imposing
a certain kind of structure of order
upon material components and why are
they doing this is a question that they
ask quite a bit under the culinary are
we doing it just for the taste are you
doing it to make money are we doing it
to fill people up are we doing it to be
healthy are we doing it to show off a
lot of the students put their there show
off pictures in facebook so they can all
look at the beautiful plating and things
like that those those are all things
that could be motivations for a cook
making a meal right those are all things
that could be a final cause now what
I've put here is kind of simplified
imagine the entire universe as being an
entire network all these clauses that
work there you've got something like
aerosols metaphysics
there you've got something like the
basic structure through which whether
you realize it or not you actually do
understand reality because of that any
given thing can't you ask these four
questions what is it made of what is the
structure or essence of it who made it
and what made it to be that way why did
they make it that way what end is good
is it serving what purpose does it have
what desires a satisfying and oftentimes
if you answer the question one of those
questions doesn't it sort of kick it
back like and I'll think about efficient
causes so your mom and dad made you who
made them
what do you call those people grandpa
and grandma and the other grandpa right
- who made them exactly oh you can - let
me just keep adding great right we
should probably like have fun great to
the 20th power grandpa grandmas god only
knows how many of them taking two - that
that power right so efficient causes can
be traced back further further
what about final causes can they be
traced back or not trace back the trace
forward well let's do that again why are
you here at Marist will serve in this
classroom why are you here that's intro
to philosophy class here on a Tuesday
morning let's go what's a purpose you
know I have deep roots
what's a purpose did nothing better to
do no I doubt that what's up to learn
about the class now why so there's one
final cause why did you want to do that
so you don't fail the final exam and why
does that matter what's the final cause
because you need to
what's up beekeeping class so you don't
have to repeat the class it's a good
reason because you need it for
graduation now why do you want to
graduate that's four years off what do
you care about that you do care for
something to me I don't want to take my
parents all off because we're paying for
this but I think for most it's probably
something like I'd like to get a good
job is that the why do you want a good
job I mean is that something that's
perfectly intelligible in itself good
jobs are just you know that's it there's
no further explanation why do people
need jobs to survive good job Gold do
more than survive right I mean you don't
need to go that it's embarrassed you
know to survive there's welfare you know
in survival but you know some of the
alarmist stuff out there says what else
yeah oh you know but so do things that
like you want to do it's like enjoying I
likes other pleasures
yeah and now notice you have desires for
other pleasures that go beyond just a
job right I think all of you want to
have a job that is satisfying then you
enjoy that true you don't want to be a
drone stamping things they can pick out
dealing with customers that you can't
stand on their bosses that you can't
stand you want to do something that
matters so that's a desire that's a good
that you're trying to achieve and you
showing up I mean we could go even
further and further and further you guys
make the point but showing up here in
class
somehow contributes in some little way
to that far off goal that far off final
cause a successful job and life that you
you're going to enjoy because it's got
other pleasures involved with them and
you can provide for your family you can
enjoy time with your friends you can go
on vacation spend time in major what
about these can these speak sort of like
traced up and down further and further
think about the material cause not with
the SHA but with your body so we take
say your muscles what am any of you know
some of you what muscles look like under
the microscope well they look like are
they very simple material sort of like
chalk they're really complicated I think
they're these words of things then you
cut the cords and there's like little
tiny cells inside those and you ever
look inside a cell smaller stuff inside
the cell and you can get more and more
powerful microscopes it turns out
there's even stuff inside that so what
does that mean that means that that
means that there is not just you know
here's the form of the body and then
here's the body's parts each of those
parts is something like this as well it
has a form muscles have striations and a
grain that's part of its form
muscles are made out of what what's the
basic building block of muscles give you
a hint when you're eating meat you're
eating muscle migas yeah protein right
protein is the material cause all the
complex stuff is you know we're gonna
call it that's the formal clause what
about the proteins themselves and they
completely basic or they made up for
something else anybody you know like
weightlifting yeah
amino acids and there's a whole bunch of
those right and they're put together in
different ways and they make different
proteins the amino acids again would be
the material cause the structure in
which they're put together to make
protein molecules would be the formal
clause so you can see you can go in all
different directions and things are
connected up together so the whole
universe can be understood in this way
now Aristotle thought that he's
uncovering something new in focusing on
final causes and final purposes and
goods and now here's something
interesting to think about the efficient
cause the efficient cause works by
moving something else by bringing it
from what Aristotle calls potentiality
into actuality you got yourself here in
the class you are a self move over
Aristotle to say right so every one of
you congratulations
you moved yourself in the right way to
get here does that far off goal of
graduation move you in the same way
that's not the way that desire desire
works by drawing and oftentimes in ways
that are difficult to articulate you
know until you actually like search
spell it out for yourself
final causes move us in a very different
way but efficient causes move us and if
people understand things only in terms
of efficient causes and not in terms of
final causes they're missing out on a
lot of intelligibility on the
understanding of things so I'm not just
to know that you can do something you
want to know whether you should do
something
whether it's a good thing to do whether
it's a purpose that's to really fully
understand something let's now look at
another about a position that Aristotle
talks about he he looks at the whole
history of metaphysics before him and
you know says who who is not got things
right and how they got it right and he
views himself as being sort of death at
the very end point of that and for us we
look at it very differently because he's
way back in in ancient Greek history but
there's a long history before him one of
the person that he's talks about is this
guy a medic please it was a really
interesting character he was revered by
some people as a god he appears - then
what we call polymath that he gets
familiar with that term and somebody
who's like they're brilliant in a whole
bunch of different areas they're able to
learn a lot of different types of things
and he wrote poetry the poetry that he
wrote was his metaphysics a bunch of
different things apparently he also
wrote Greek tragedies he didn't even
live in Greece he lived in Sicily which
at that time was a Greek colony before
Sicily was Italian
now what did him pedak Lee say or do
that was so interesting we don't know
that much because we don't actually have
most of his writings we have just
fragments and Harris mobile phones was a
bit about them didn't you remember
before we came up with our big periodic
table of elements what people thought
the elements were not there are four of
them usually yeah
yeah on the right track fire and one and
they would connect these remember when
we were talking about Eric Zemeckis and
his speech Eric's Emma Chris was talking
about the hot the cold the the dry the
wet and the elements these were her what
happened pedicle he said were the
elements earth air fire and water
sometimes later on they would add a 5th
element the quintessence the word
quintessence means to element is Latin
for development
modesta
fire was supposed to be hot and dry air
hot and wet and cold and wet or cold and
dry the different quality is tied in
with this and I'm kind of loose luck
everything is made out of these and I've
had to pick four basic building blocks
these aren't bad you know Chinese five
element theory substitutes in metal and
wood in place of birth right there's
other element theories out there like
this but a lot of people came up with
with theories and so much of us now
you're you're not like a earthy person
or a fire person or in the air person so
how do we get to things like you guys
well you're made up of things that
themselves are made up of these basic
elements so your bones I don't know
exactly how much harder let's say maybe
your bones are a mixture earth and fire
and air in the right proportion set up
the right way that sounds pretty good so
far
that makes start making sense other
things you know when you start getting
sick maybe you've got too much water in
your system or too much fire in your
system you know these four humors
together with that later and Greek
medicine which still was used in like
the 1700s this doesn't explain some
things though does it
why should these elements come together
why should they work in the way that
they do and paddock lease doesn't
introduce this well this is the way it
works
Aristotle says he's missing out on some
lies and pet achlys brings some other
things yeah
love or friendship three words
philia which generally means friendship
but the Greeks
you know the can interchangeable strife
or hatred nakos not that interestingly
enough not some of the other Greek words
that you could use for hatred they
haven't quite a few you're just at 180
for this well they have a vocabulary for
something you know that you're doing a
lot strife breaks things apart love
binds things together right think about
human beings when human beings are at
odds with each other they don't want to
hang out with each other right they want
to be in different places if they have a
relationship the relationship breaks up
love brings people together it makes
them into the one sort of unity and
couple think about families this word
for families of family in which there's
love everybody will actually get
together in the same room families in
which there's lots of hatred funerals
and baptisms and marriages are terrible
occasions because you can't put them all
in the same room because they repel each
other can you look at political
communities or teams or classes or
things like that this way you know do
you have a sense for example school
spirit here at Marist are you proud to
be a Maris student as proud as you would
be if you were at some other places that
would be a feeling of love that is
binding you together with all the other
people at Marist you're sort of like the
elements love runs through the entire
universe this sounds like somebody that
we read before
sounds like Eric's impetuses account
doesn't Eric's Emma kiss is very much
like a pedigrees now there's some
problems with this Aristotle points out
this doesn't only answer a bunch of
anything
why should
actually bind everything together why
should strife what made those be what
they are what is the explanation for
those and peda Cleese doesn't have an
answer to that there's a lot of lies
that he is unable to or didn't or
perhaps didn't have the opportunity to
ask an answer when putting together his
his metaphysical scheme Aristotle says
these are questions that actually would
need an answer there's other problems
too
here's here's the way in pedagogic
originally everything was all bound
together in one big lump mass in poet
you know who knows even what to call
everything was all one so there weren't
any like people or desks or pieces of
chalk or bits of the air or cups of
coffee or anything like that because
those are distinct things right you're
not her you you guys are not the same
person this is not a sci-fi you know
weird Canon you're melting into one kind
of scenario you're somebody different
than him right have you found yourself
looking in the mirror and looking like a
mutant what happened something went
wrong right vice versa right this is a
big surprise that's because we're
distinctive things were separate from
each other if we were in fact blended
into one this is something to think
about to remember Aristophanes saying
what human beings really want is to find
their ideal person and then be welded
into the same thing to be fused with
them would you really be you anymore at
that point if you truly were completely
interfused with that person you might
not be the same being anymore you would
just be that with that new thing imagine
everything in the universe that was the
original lump then stripe which is he
says
outermost came in and started splitting
things up so stripe is really
responsible in aircon and pedak Lee is
cosmology its theory of the universe for
making things break apart into what they
are now as as broken apart you know like
in your body you'd better have love in
your body or else your body's going to
break down into its component parts you
don't want strength at that point but
strife was necessary in order for beings
to even be to be the kind of beings that
they are to be determined an aerosol
says well that doesn't really make sense
you're gonna decide one way or the other
is love making things come together and
therefore exist or is it strife that's
making things come together and he might
be able to Lund fear its impetus but he
also has a number of other arguments to
these sites and pedak lee is is making
love be an efficient cause it's love
which binds things together which makes
them be what they are think about love
putting these trucks together and now
they're one chalk but love is also part
of the composition so love is both the
material cause in an efficient causing
sense again you gotta pick one of the
other it's not going to work for it to
be both of these at the same time that
just doesn't really make sense so
Aristotle is considering a theory of
love or friendship which makes it
central to everything makes it something
that pervades the entire universe and
all the ways in which it works and he
says that doesn't really work instead
what we need to think about is we're
going to think about the good because
love is it good right
something that makes more sense is the
notion of final clause as being the good
which we desire what we're going to
close with is thinking about is there a
final good for the entire universe is
there some purpose to this whole mess
that we're in Aristotle says yeah
there is but his answer is not going to
be like something that you know the
answers that were more used to hearing
from Jews and Christians and Muslims
model-t is saying something like God
community your purpose or something
Aristotle says that it's going to be
something in movable something that is
eternal so therefore that sounds a lot
like God doesn't it turn all immovable
it's going to be thought thinking itself
thought and desire for Aristotle are
kind of similar both of them moved
without necessarily being moved both of
them make things be what they are that's
what it causes that which makes
something be with this desire draws us
without itself being the object being
drawn right if I desire to spend time
with you I have to actually go over by
you and make the time to spend the time
with you that doesn't actually change
you in the process if I desire coffee I
can bring the coffee to me right but in
a sense of what I'm doing is I'm the
shortening the distance between myself
and coffee thought simile
we didn't have much time something to
make this very very short thought
similarly works upon itself and can be
moving other things without being moved
thought Aristotle things is sort of the
highest form of existence in the
universe and so whatever it is that's
best is going to be thinking about what
thinking about things no thinking about
itself thinking about things and we
human beings we can participate in this
a little bit and that's what we're doing
when we're learning when we're doing
when we're following our come full
circle when we're following our innate
desire to know as rational beings we are
participating in the thing that's best
in the universe the thing that drives
everything else and gets everything else
so that's where we leave a lot